so the decisions facing the executive
today have not been straightforward
there are many factors
which have been assessed and balanced
but what is clear is that we must
proceed with great care
and with caution we need our decisions
to be both safe
and sustainable and i'm determined that
through the proper sequencing of actions
as we emerge
from these restrictions that we leave
lockdowns
in the rear view and that we do not step
backwards again
so our clear priority at this point is
to continue to keep the
r rate below one uh for our cases and to
achieve this
it is considered that a full lifting of
the current restrictions is not
possible at this point so the executive
has reluctantly
accepted the analysis from our health
advisors that the restrictions will need
to be in place
for four more weeks and we will conduct
another full review
of the regulations on the 18th of march
and i know that that will come as a
disappointment but it is a pragmatic
and a sensible approach and it's
important to be clear
that we will only maintain restrictions
which are proportionate and necessary
and so we will keep them under continual
review
on an ongoing basis so we will be taking
small steps
as we monitor and assess before
moving to any next stages as the prime
minister has said we will be informed
by data and not by dates but our first
step forward will be the gradual
return of schools from monday march the
8th
preschool and nursery children will
return
as well as primary one to three to face
face-to-face teaching
with effect from the 8th of march
obviously
those children who are the children of
key workers
and of other year groups can continue to
attend school
students engaged in completing
qualifications such as gcse
af and a level and other vocational
qualifications
so principally years 12 to 14 will
return to full-time face-to-face
teaching with effect from the 22nd
of march